number 88 CD lamb 11 reception 151 yards
one touchdown the first player NFL
history with three straight gains with
10 plus receptions and 150 plus
reception yards he is without a doubt a
number one receiver I went up to CD and
I was like well you know AJ Brown he had
six games straight over 125 after he had
about 140 in the game he said you ever
see somebody go for 150 three games in a
row I said nope I haven't if I get my
top three right now who's playing at
Elite level right now has to be Tyreek
Hill AJ Brown and CD lamb I don't think
it's a discussion there was questions
going into the season can cidd be a
number one and he answered the call cidi
is a number one receiver he's breaking
numbers box office whatever you want to
put it cidd is that guy and we need to
start putting respect on his
name